My fellow comrades! It's me! PewDiePie!
What's that? There's something different about me? Huh?
It must be.. It must be the glasses.
Oh, what? There's still something?
Huh? It must be the merch! The new сука блять merch!
Very nice!
If you're a real сука check out the link in the description!
Limited time available only!
Now let's get on with the video,
*awkward look*
Why are you crying? (Your beard iS GONE!!)
Listen up!
Okay,
The beard meme was getting old
and all memes must die...
so stop crying, stop being such a baby,
and stop crying do you wanna
To look like this, huh?
Pathetic. Why do I look 12? (TT you do)
*chuckles*
Then we're gonna take anything I say seriously now? *laughs*
[14 year old self] Hey guys it's me PewDiePie from 2003!
People keep saying we need to stop making dumb people famous! But I always say,
But then who are we going to laugh at? Who are we supposed to ridicule and feel better about ourselves,
because at least there's one person out there that is doing worse than me! From people like sexy vegan, to
JacksFilms to, now, Woahvicky, remember Woahvicky? Vickywoah?
The girl who thinks she's from african-american descent? "in this hotel. I knew it. I knew I was black girl."
I mean how could you not remember such beauty and such grace?
For those who you don't know who Woahwicky is, she's a master of motivational speech.
"STAWP HATING! STOP, STOP THAT SHIT NOW, I LOVE EVERYBODY, I LOVE EVERYBODY, I LOVE YOU! STAWP HATING!"
She's a master in the art of dancing....
*dances like an idiot*
aND,  a master swimmer!
*holds nose* (pathetic)
*beautiful laugh*
It's my favorite clip! *Laughs*
Let's see what she's been up to lately....
hmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmmm?
She was in a fight with Danielle Bregoli!
What? The cash me outside girl! This is some really interesting news,
It's like water, fighting water.
[ clip of 2 female monkeys arguing ]
Why is she wearing the hoodie like that? *laughs*
[more arguing lol]
Why is there a five-year-old there? What is happening?
[more... and louder as the female monkeys argue more ]
Where's your mom? *chuckles*
Can someone tell me?
*uncontrollable grinning*
Why is there a little kid here? Jesus!
[and more... ( Oo OO AH Aah) ]
Martial artists will study this video, to learn the master fighting technique. That legend, every day,
when Danielle Bregoli and Woahwicky had a fight.
[more more...]
Oh! But she comes from behind! And tries to hit WoahWicky right in her worst spot,
which is where her hair is! A lot of people don't know this, but WoahWicky's  weak spot is located right there,
I guess Daniel Bregoli must be studying us! Whoa-
Whoa-
*confused laugh*
I don't know if I should laugh or cry at this, it's just so ridiculous,
you have all these adults involved as well, but
nothing really gets stopped. I don't know how this is even possible? Pewds from the future here! Sorry to interrupt,
Have I told you about ASS?
It's coming out on every console ever, in May! Check it out! Link in the description! Join the discord! Have some fun!
Okay, keep going on with the video! (Thank youuu)
WoahWicky of course, had the perfect response to this, in the most mature,
well-mannered way possible, which is what I expect from, such a high class character like WoahWicky. Let's watch!
Whoa-
She's uh, showing off some of the, the moves that she.
(couldn't hold the laugh in)
That she displayed earlier in the fight.
Brilliant stuff, really good technique there.
you want to hit them as low and fast as possible.
(some kind of stone age dancing)
*swimming*
Did she just lose the fight against herself there? What is happening?
She's fighting air and she's losing... that bri-.... Well done.
How do you fall from that??
*struggling*
*flapping legs*
(frustrated dancing TT)
It's really, it really, is the, the best way to display dominance is to just fight thin air.
I can't stop thinking about the five-year-old, I need to find out... I need to find out who she is. LilTayyyyyy?
Is that her?
Is that her uh... profile pic?
Okay, that's kind of brilliant. We live in a society. We truly live, in a society.
[ Asian Dora the Explorer's Instagram video]
(cringy stuff and swearing)
*thinking about lil' tay*
*blaming existence*
*why are we still here?*
*finally found the reason to not live*
*finding his words*
I feel like I'm not, I'm not allowed to say anything
cuz she's, only NINE YEARS OLD
but she's flexing your mommas rennnnt?
[ Asian Dora the Explorer's Instagram video]
I mean she's right about pretty much everything
she says so I don't really know what, I don't really have any counter points or counter arguments here,
that bed does cost more than a Lamborghini, and she does make more money than what my rent costs.
(rich spoilt brat blabbing about money and car)
I Feel like, anything that has lil in front of it has some sort of chromosome....
deformity. There has to be some scientific research on that to prove that 'cause- *Laughs*
(bragging brat and the car not her's)
STOP HATING ON ME!!
If you are flexing, then aren't you technically hating?
I feel like this whole Instagram culture has just become.
It- It started off as well (?) but now..
It's ... It's like they realized they can monetize
And they just play it up even more and, and then, you have all these, these, kids in the comments just hating like,
(12 year olds) Oh, you're so stupid! You're a baby! Uhhhh, you need- you're so dumb!
When they're obviously just portraying a character or....
What's it called...?
Exaggerating their whole, uh, shtick or whatever. You can see WoahWicky at the end of her video just smiling like "haha gotcha!".
*Noise pollution to my ears*
(quite inaudible blabber)
It sort of reminds me of the Westboro Baptist Church
You know holding their signs, that are hateful and everyone just hates on them.
But they, they keep doing it because they think they have a purpose for it.
Uh, uh, I think maybe I'm reading too much into this,
but, it seems like the same thing here 'cause they just keep doubling down on how, how dumb they can act and that makes them,
More money, and they think that ever, uh, anyone that just hates them doesn't understand that the fact that they're just playing it up,
they're not actually that stupid, but in reality
Yes,
you are, you started this whole thing, because you were dumb, and just
Because you're now playing into it doesn't change the fact that you are, in fact, incredibly stupid
What I always wonder is... how do they monetize it? You know they're always flexing money,
Instagram doesn't really get you that money unless you do some sponsor deal,
It's not like you have ads on your photos,
Or, it doesn't matter if your video gets a lot of views.
WHERE DOES THE MONEY COME FROM??
The only sponsored posts.
I found, is this one.
(LOTS OF NON-SENSE SWEARING AND FELIX "WOaH"-ing in the back)
(shes the worst commercial model ever TT)
(the hair looks better than her swearing)
Tchhh-- *chuckles*
*laughs*
NOW THATS! THATS HOW YOU SPONSER CONTENT!!
Just watch from WoahWicky! *Laughs* just watch from WoahWicky... [Inaudible ¯\_(ツ)_/¯]
*blabbering in alien voice*
[Gibberish]
Brad, one, is now going to subtitle this, in case you can't understand, uh,
Brad has watched a lot of her videos, he's a big fan.
So he will subtitle this for us this first piece because I didn't get any of that (He better, because I didn't understand any of that either)
Okay, so she has a song. That's how she, so she got a record deal. Is that it? Who? The-?
My follow-up question is, who buys the song?
WHO'S BUYING THE SONG??
Why would anyone buy the song?
WHO IS THE CONSUMER OF THE SONG???
"Ching Chong Ching Chong Ching Chong Beech"
meow meow meow meow meow (WTF??)
(She wrote a whole b-shit song about Asians)
(PPL watching: Don't call Asians 'Ching Chong' or 'Chinki', it's very rude and inappropriate)
Really good lyrics! At least we get to laugh at something... Sure, they get money, and they get famous
but, we get good entertainment. This is great li - This is great stuff!
You have to appreciate it.
[a really immature girl on a single valentines day]
(cuz ofcourse, who'd want to be lovers with headache?)
(need meds? Call ambulance?)
(imwoahvickey = forever alone)
How to make a WoahWicky video: (100% Accurate Tutorial Insert Here)